well we're talking about coaches who are
willing to call out their teams call out
their players you know get into a little
bit make you be you know thick-skinned
let's get to john gruden john gruden
this was what he said about isaiah
johnson as he broke up that last play of
the game said he was baptized in the nfl
here's gordon
you know he got he got baptized today in
the nfl and uh mullen comes out of the
game and arnett's
on the sideline and we needed somebody
to step up keyshawn nixon hurt his groin
and thank goodness for isaiah johnson
and his length
and um
like like you said you you got to give
him credit we gave him a game ball and
uh we gave brandon parker a game ball
for their for their work today and on on
uh
as we were short-handed
i tell you the half a million in the
next 100 100k fine uh john gruden's
wearing that mask now how do you take
the sound bite with the bat
i mean he's wearing that mask now you
love to see it how do you think the
baptism line there at the end rodney it
was it was up to here dude it was like a
hundred percent
it was just like 100 covered i remember
i had a situation like that i was in
training camp as a rookie and i was
going against natron means i don't know
if you ever heard of natron means but he
was our running back in 1994 he's about
5 10
245 pounds kind of built up like jerome
bettis
and we're in training camp and the coach
says get out there rookie and go play so
i was well i guess while i was with the
starters i met natron means in the hole
i hit him as hard as i could and when i
woke up i was in the training room
i had like a concussion like my first
nfl hit was with natron means and he
knocked me out i was i was uh in in in
the training room with a concussion but
of course he practiced the morning
practice he practiced the afternoon
practice so i would look at that as my
baptism in the
nfl
so that was your baptism it sounded like
sounds like isaiah had a little bit more
of a fun comfortable baptism than you
did that sounds like a little tougher
version
absolutely man it's a little tougher
version
so the raiders in general let's just go
big picture with this team because we've
seen them look really good we've seen
them look really bad they're now
starting to win again
is the foundation of this program moving
in the right direction do you believe
that john gruden will have this as a
winning team that can make a potential
deep playoff run at some point
which direction do you see them headed
they're getting better man i mean they
they're acquiring a lot of young talent
on defense guys in the secondary that
can definitely play um offensively i
think the big question is i mean they
have weapons the big question is still
to me
is derek carr can he win him a super
bowl and
i believe that he could possibly in the
next year or so get him to the playoffs
but i just don't think he's the guy to
win a super bowl i i like what he's
doing this year he's incredibly accurate
he's making some plays he's showing a
lot more leadership um but
that's the question can he get them to
the next level they have an offer they
have all pro tight end they have a great
running back
young really good wide receivers even
nelson aguilar is stepping up making
plays i think john gruden and mike may
have done a terrific job these first
couple years of turning this program
around they're going to continue these
guys know football so they're going to
get football players in there and john
gru knows how to coach i think he's
doing great
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports